l'exécutif sur la corde raide le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand est
revenu sur la situation critique en
ile-de-france région dans laquelle des
mesures de confinement reste pour le
moment écartée malgré des indicateurs
préoccupants pour éviter d'en arriver là
la stratégie de transfert massif de
patients on va s'étendre dans le
territoire francilien la situation
épidémique et sanitaires en ile de
france nous préoccupent tout
particulièrement
même si la tendance est un peu moins
forte depuis quelques jours l'incidence
la circulation du virus il est élevé 350
mille trois cent cinquante quatre pour
cent mille habitants
ils sont enregistrées en moyenne chaque
semaine est d'ores et déjà nous
préparons des transferts importants de
patients vers les autres régions qui
pourrait avoir lieu dès cette fin de
semaine
quand je dis important c'est qu'on parle
là de dizaines voire voire de centaines
de patients qui pourraient être évacués
de l'île de france vers d'autres
hôpitaux d'autres régions du territoire
national
la donne pourrait toutefois changer si
la pression devenait trop forte sur les
hôpitaux les autorités pourraient alors
appliqué aux franciliens des mesures
telles que celles imposées aux habitants
du dunkerquois et des alpes maritimes
le ministre de la santé qui a fait un
point sur le vaillant britannique devenu
majoritaire a réalisé un bilan à date
concernant la campagne de vaccination
les variantes sont de fait plus
contagieux que le coc vite 19 classique
et le remplacent progressivement la part
de variants dit britannique est
supérieure à 60 7% et la part des
variants dit sud africain et brésilien
elle est bien contrôlée et maîtrisée
puisque elle reste aux alentours de 6%
en 24 heures
286 milles français ont reçu une
injection de vaccin c'est un record
depuis le début de notre campagne de
vaccination au total ce sont ainsi
quatre millions cinq cent quarante cinq
mille français qui ont reçu une première
injection et 2 millions 165 mille
français qui ont reçu leurs deux
injections
le gouvernement compte donc plus que
jamais sur l'efficacité de la
vaccination de masse pour éclaircir
l'horizon sanitaires alors qu'un nouveau
remède celui de johnson and johnson
vient d'être autorisée dans l'union
européenne